JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
GREG GUTFELD, AND BRET BAIER.
IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE IS GETTING READY FOR
A BRIEFING WHILE A PARTISAN
FIGHT PLAYS OUT ON CAPITOL HILL.
THE HOUSE VOTING NOW ON A NEW
STIMULUS BILL THAT INCLUDES MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
REPUBLICANS ARE PUMMELING
NANCY PELOSI SAYING THAT SHE
DELAYED THE PROCESS FOR DAYS
CAUSING UNNECESSARY SUFFERING.
THE G.O.P. ALSO PINNING LAST
WEEK’S UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS ON
THE SPEAKER AFTER ANOTHER
4 MILLION AMERICANS LOST THEIR
JOBS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO THOSE 4.4 MILLION
AMERICANS THAT WERE LAID OFF
THIS WEEK, CONGRESS OWES YOU AN
APOLOGY.
YOU PUT EVERYTHING INTO YOUR
BUSINESS TO SUCCEED, AND
GOVERNMENT TOLD THEM THEY HAD TO
SHUT DOWN FOR THE HEALTH OF THE
NATION.
THEY MADE A SACRIFICE.
BUT THEY GOT SACRIFICED FOR
POLITICS LAST WEEK.
>> Dana: NANCY PELOSI SAYS IT
IS REPUBLICANS WHO DELAYED THE
MUCH NEEDED MONEY.
>> MITCH McCONNELL LIKES TO
SAY THAT WE DELAYED THE BILL,
NO, HE DELAYED THE BILL.
WE ARE VERY PLEASED THAT HE
FINALLY CAME AROUND TO THE FACT
THAT WE HAD TO GO FORWARD WITH
THIS.
SO HE WAS THE ONE WASTING TIME.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, LET’S
START WITH YOU, JESSE.
YESTERDAY YOU SAID YOU ARE A
NONPARTISAN GUY.
WE WILL GO TO YOU FOR YOUR TAKE
AS TO WHO IS WINNING ON THE
POLITICS OF THIS, BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICANS SEEM TO ME TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO REALLY TRY TO PIN
SOMETHING ON NANCY PELOSI, BUT
YET, SHE IS BLAMING THEM.
>> Jesse: I DON’T MIND THAT
NANCY SQUEEZED MITCH, I MIND
THAT IT TOOK HER A WEEK TO DO
IT.
IT DOES NOT TAKE THAT LONG, BUT
SHE DRAGS IT OUT.
TRYING TO STEAL TRUMP’S THUNDER
AND MAKE DEMOCRATS ROLL OVER AT
HER PARLIAMENTARY MANEUVERS.
IF SHE WAS A REPUBLICAN AND TRY
TO POSTURE UP LIKE THIS FOR A
WEEK DURING THE PANDEMIC, THEY
WOULD HUNT HER DOWN LIKE A DOG.
AND HE WOULD SEE LOWER THIRDS ON
CABLE TELEVISION THAT SAID,
PELOSI LAYOFFS.
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT HAPPEN.
HERE’S HOW QUICKLY SHE HANDLED
DESPERATE TO GET MITCH ON THE
PHONE.
AND GO, MITCH, IT’S NANCY.
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO IS THIS.
I NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY
FOR HOSPITALS, TESTING, AND
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS, AND WE
NEED IT DONE SOON.
MITCH SAYS, HEY, NANCE, WE CAN’T
DO THIS RIGHT NOW.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
CAN WE DO IT IN A SEPARATE BILL?
NANCY SAYS, WE DO IT NOW MY WAY
OR THE HIGHWAY, AND IF YOU
DISAGREE WITH ME I WILL SLEEP ON
IT FOR A WEEK.
MITCH SAYS OKAY, CLICK.
THEY CALLED HER AIDES AND ADD
LANGUAGE, THEY CALL
STEVE MNUCHIN, SAY, TREASURY, WE
ARE GOING TO NEED A LITTLE BIT
FOR THIS, THAT, AND THE OTHER
THING, AND THEY GET IT DONE AND
AN AFTERNOON.
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT NANCY DID.
SHE DRAGGED IT OUT SO SHE COULD
HAVE THE SPOTLIGHT, SO THAT SHE
COULD CLAIM CREDIT FOR GETTING
WHAT SHE WANTED AND GETS CREDIT
FOR THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
IT’S NO SURPRISE TO ME, SHE
DELAYED IT TO THE BORDER.
SHE DELAYED AID TO FARMERS.
SHE HELD UP THE U.S. NCA.
SHE DID THIS WITH SMALL
BUSINESS, WITH THE UNEMPLOYED.
THIS IS WHAT SHE DOES.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL COMPLAIN,
BUT THEY LOST THE HOUSE IN 2018.
THEIR VOTERS DID NOT SHOW UP.
SO YOU SHOW UP IN NOVEMBER, YOU
KICK HER OUT.
THAT’S HOW YOU SOLVE PROBLEMS IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Dana: GREG, WHICH SIDE IS
MORE PERSUASIVE ON THIS POINT?
BECAUSE WHAT PEOPLE REALLY WANT
IS THEY WANT THE MONEY.
THEY WANT THE BANKS TO BE ABLE
TO FULFILL THEIR LOANS.
THEY DON’T ONLY CARE ABOUT THE
POLITICS OF IT.
DO THE POLITICS MATTER AT ALL?
>> Greg: I DON’T THINK EITHER
SIDE IS PERSUASIVE IN THIS AT
ALL.
AMERICA ISN’T DIVIDED LIKE THEM.
IT’S JUST DISGUSTED.
THEIR LIVES ARE BASICALLY
HANGING IN THE BALANCE WHILE
THESE PARTISAN POOP HEADS, AND
YES, I SAID POOP HEADS AT 5:00.
THEY CANNOT SHUT THEM OF THEIR
PARTISANSHIP WHEN PEOPLE ARE
DYING.
AND A LOT OF THEM SUGGEST CHALK
OVER JOB NUMBERS, BUT THEY
REFUSED TO SAY WHAT THEY THINK
ONE SHOULD DO ABOUT IT.
SO THEY HAVE NO SKIN IN THE
GAME.
THEY WILL SIT THERE AND THEY
WILL GO, OH, MY GOSH, OKAY, WHAT
WOULD YOU DO?
WELL, WE NEED TO GIVE MORE
MONEY.
NO, YOU NEED TO MAKE AN ADULT
DECISION.
SO WE ARE WATCHING ESSENTIALLY A
SLOW DISINTEGRATION OF A
CIVILIZATION, RIGHT?
WHICH MEANS ON THE UPSIDE, WE
MIGHT ALREADY ALMOST BE THERE,
BECAUSE I THINK INSTINCTIVELY WE
KNOW WHERE WE CAN GO BEFORE
POVERTY, ANARCHY, AND ULTIMATELY
WAR, BECAUSE THAT’S WHERE IT
WILL GO IF WE DON’T PULL THE
NOSE UP ON THE PLANE.
SO MY OPTIMISM IS BASED ON HOW
GRIM IT’S GETTING.
BECAUSE THAT MEANS WE ARE ALMOST
THERE, AND WE CAN’T GO ON LIKE
THIS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A TERRIBLE
RELATIONSHIP, BUT WE CAN’T GO ON
LIKE THIS.
IT HAS TO END.
SO HERE’S A POSITIVE WAY TO LOOK
AT THIS.
THE BAD NEWS FIRST.
THIS WILL HAPPEN AGAIN.
TO THE GOOD NEWS, IT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
WHICH MEANS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
GET THROUGH THIS ONE THIS TIME.
AND EVERYTHING WE LEARN IS GOING
TO MAKE THE NEXT TIME A PIECE OF
CAKE.
WE WILL PULL BACK AND KNOW WHEN
THE COAST IS CLEAR.
WHAT WE ARE GOING THROUGH NOW IS
NOT JUST FOR NOW.
ALL THE PAIN AND SUFFERING, IT’S
FOR LATER.
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO PAY
OFF HER FUTURE GENERATIONS WHEN
THE PANDEMIC COMES AROUND.
SO THAT’S A GOOD WAY TO LOOK AT
THIS.
I JUST WISH, BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE MAKING THE
SACRIFICES, THE POLITICIANS
WOULD STEP UP AND MAKE THEIR
SACRIFICES TOO.
AND STOP BEING A-HOLS.
>> Dana: ’S BETWEEN ONE, THE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE SPEAKING
ABOUT EACH OTHER IN VITRIOLIC
PERSONAL TERMS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS
PANDEMIC.
AND OBVIOUSLY TENSIONS ARE
RUNNING HIGH, BUT WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF ALL OF THAT?
>> Juan: I JUST THINK IT IS
BAD FORM, DANA.
I THINK IT IS BAD FORM TO PLAY
THE POLITICAL BLAME GAME WHEN
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING.
BASICALLY I AM ECHOING WHAT
JESSE AND GREG SAID.
I THINK THAT IT IS REGRETTABLE.
AND I THINK THAT WHAT YOU REALLY
NEED HERE IS TO FOCUS ON WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO HELP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND GET THEM EFFECTIVE
HELP.
IF SO, WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
DELAY, I DON’T THINK THAT THERE
IS ANY DELAY TO CRAFT
LEGISLATION THAT IS EFFECTIVE IN
TERMS OF DELIVERING NECESSARY
HELP TO PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING
THROUGH A HEALTH EMERGENCY,, AND
ECONOMIC EMERGENCY.
AND WHAT WE SAW LAST TIME BY THE
WAY IS THAT REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS SIGNED ON TO A BILL
THAT DID NOT GET THE JOB DONE,
DID NOT STOP THE JOB LOSSES, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND INSTEAD WHAT WE ARE
READING IN THE PAPERS IS THAT
THE BIG BANKS WERE REWARDING THE
WEALTHY CLIENTS, AND SMALL
BUSINESS DID NOT GET THE AID
THAT THEY NEEDED.
AND TODAY YOU HERE, YOU KNOW,
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MACCONNELL SAYING, OH, LET THE
STATES GO BANKRUPT.
FORGET THE POLICY.
WHY WOULD YOU SAY SUCH A THING?
>> Greg: THAT IS A DIFFERENT
POINT.
IT IS A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE IDEA.
IT’S AN IDEA.
>> Dana: LET ME GO THERE,
BECAUSE I THINK --
>> Bret: LET’S JUST SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT.
THERE WAS A CLEAN BILL THAT ONCE
THEY FOUND OUT THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESS POT WAS GOING TO BE
DRY, THERE WAS A CLEAN BILL TO
PUT MORE MONEY IN.
NANCY PELOSI DID NOT GO FORWARD
WITH THAT PERIOD IT, THE END,
STOP THERE.
SO YES, THEY WANTED TO DO OTHER
THINGS, DEMOCRATS DID.
BUT TO HAVE AN ANSWER THAT SAYS
THAT IT WAS MITCH McCONNELL
WHO DELAYED IS REALLY POLITICAL
JIU-JITSU.
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT PUSHES BACK AND SAYS, WAIT
A SECOND, IN THAT TIME THAT
THERE WAS A DELAY, THERE ARE X
NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT HAD TO
MAKE THE DECISION, I HAVE NOT
GOTTEN THE MONEY, SO I HAVE TO
LET THESE PEOPLE GO.
SO WHEN THE NUMBER GOES UP
4.4 MILLION ON UNEMPLOYMENT,
THERE IS A REASON THAT IT GOES
UP THAT WAY.
AND THAT DELAY IS PART OF IT.
>> Dana: I’M BEING TOLD THAT
WE HAVE EXTRA TIME, DO WE HAVE
THE MACCONNELL THOUGHT, THE
POINT THAT JUAN GOT UP ABOUT THE
STATES AND WHAT
MITCH McCONNELL SAID ABOUT THE
FUNDING FOR THE STATES, AND
CUOMO’S RESPONSE, WE WILL GET
REACTION ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> I WAS CERTAINLY IN FAVOR OF
THE ISSUE FOR THE BACKUP ROUTE,
AND IF IT SAVES SOME CITIES.
MY GUESS IS THAT THEIR FIRST
CHOICE FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS TO BORROW MONEY
AND SEND IT DOWN TO THEM NOW SO
THAT THEY DON’T HAVE TO DO THAT.
THAT’S NOT SOMETHING I’M GOING
TO BE IN FAVOR OF.
>> NEW YORK PUTS IN MORE MONEY
TO THE FEDERAL POT THAN IT TAKES
OUT.
HIS STATE TAKES OUT MORE THAN IT
PUTS IN.
SENATOR McCONNELL, WHO IS
BAILED OUT HERE?
IT’S YOUR STATE THAT IS LIVING
ON THE MONEY THAT WE GENERATE.
>> Dana: GREG, LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO YOU.
THERE WAS A BUDGET THAT WAS
PASSED IN NEW YORK STATE.
I DON’T THINK THERE WAS A BUDGET
CUT IN IT.
THIS WAS BEFORE CORONAVIRUS, BUT
THIS IS GOING TO BE A HUGE
ISSUE, BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
OF STATES THAT WERE NOT IN GOOD
FINANCIAL STATE BEFORE THE
CORONAVIRUS, SO WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT?
>> Greg: IT’S INTERESTING THAT
BEFORE THERE WERE VIRUSES, THERE
WERE CITIES RUN BY DEMOCRATS
THAT WERE DECLARING BANKRUPTCY
WITHOUT THE HELP OF A PANDEMIC.
THEY WERE JUST DECLARING
BANKRUPTCY OR BROKE BY SPENDING.
SO I DON’T BUY IT.
THIS WHOLE SEGMENT JUST ANGERS
ME, BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING, WE
ARE JUST FALLING BACK INTO THE
SAME MISTAKES THAT WE MAKE EVERY
TIME, BUT THIS TIME IS
DIFFERENT, BECAUSE THESE
MISTAKES CAN COST YOU THE
CIVILIZATION.
IF THIS IS NOT LIKE, WE ARE NOT
LIKE ARGUING OVER A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
WE ARE NOT ARGUING OVER WHETHER
WE, YOU KNOW, CLOSE DOWN SOME OF
THE PARKS BECAUSE WE ARE HAVING
FRUSTRATION.
THIS IS NOT EVEN AN ENCASEMENT
DISCUSSION.
THIS IS WHERE OUR LEADERS CANNOT
EVEN MAKE AN ADULT DECISION
WITHOUT ACTUALLY -- WHICH
ACTUALLY COULD RUIN EVERYBODY’S
LIVES.
WE COULD ALL BE DESTROYED.
THAT’S WHY I HAVE TO STOP EVERY
TIME I’M ABOUT TO SAY SOMETHING,
BECAUSE IT’S GOING TO USE 16
DIFFERENT WORDS THAT BEGIN WITH
THE LETTER F.
>> Dana: MAYBE WE SHOULD JUST